[Applaudissements]
voulait voir on s'est accroché dans des
émissions télévisées me suis regardé le
star d'un coït rsa vont dehors j'ai raté
même dans tous les slips regarder ya pas
de slip mais certains dans les émissions
regardées
j'aurais peut-être une idée de ce qu'on
pourrait faire cet après midi
cloud tu as commencé tout seul
[Musique]
oui oui ça c'est bon c'est à dire avec
cent à la fin du papier des vieux toi tu
me donnes la rose ce soir ça va être pas
mal au gouvernement à l aventure
[Musique]
marie martin
acceptes tu cette roue allaoua non non
non je n'ai pas vu de si près on était
l'occasion la respectant enfin on va
tous trouvé un géranium ou un truc mais
je vais garder la rose pour cynthia
salut tes paroles devaient pas être très
très amoureux au monde
enfin jérémy décompte des corps de huit
années de hausse mais elles pèsent les
milliards d'euros l'assurance chômage
est aujourd'hui dans le rouge
les partenaires sociaux syndicats et
patronat ont quatre mois devant eux pour
sauver inédite
fabien shadow et pascal choquenet on le
vit la première est ce que tu aimes bien
les blondes et brunes ou tu t'en fiches
bombe avant mon style c'est varié mais
enfin si je devais citer une personne ce
sera vraiment valérie benaïm quoi c'est
vraiment c'est ma came à 2000 donc pas
une bimbo
non moi je veux valérie benaïm soit son
sexe sa coupe de cheveux la mpaa
on est en moi
[Musique]
sandrine important samedi
camarade soudan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]